c'est la septième dans les yvelines la
maison france services de
saint-cyr-l'ecole accompagne depuis juin
dernier les habitants de la ville et de
l'extérieur dans leurs démarches
administratives et numérique du
quotidien on a beaucoup été confrontés à
des personnes qui nous disaient qu'ils
ne savaient plus faire qu'ils étaient
perdus qui est qu'il n'arrivait plus à
voir le bon interlocuteur la
complexification des démarches elle-même
amènent leur lot de frein par rapport à
l'accès au droit et avait couple est
effectivement aux difficultés de
proximité de désengagement effectivement
des opérateurs et de dématérialisation
bas on se retrouve souvent dans des
situations de rupture j'ai vu la caf
partir j'ai vu la direction des impôts
partir le commissariat partir la cpam et
là il y avait vraiment un net besoin
pour j'ai envie de dire rapatrier les
services publics sur notre territoire
communal sur place un accueil ce rendez
vous avec trois salariés qui ont comme
mission d'informer et d'accompagner de
nombreux partenaires sont concernés
comme l'assurance maladie la poste pôle
emploi ou encore la caf la structure met
en place différents accommodements donc
à cet endroit une personne peut venir se
faire aider pour une déclaration
d'impôts a démarré un dossier de
retraite des démarches qui sont
quelquefois compliqué lorsqu'on est seul
devant son ordinateur à la fois
un point d'accueil des points d'accueil
numérique avec des bureaux
confidentialité dans lesquels on
accompagne les personnes mais on est
aussi un point d'accueil numérique en
accès libre où les gens peuvent venir
effectivement se connecter et réaliser
leurs démarches avec leur autonomie le
senior le jeune l'ancien la femme c'est
tout public favoriser l'accès aux
services publics à tous les habitants du
territoire c'est une priorité pour cette
ville qui comprend 37 % de logements
sociaux